voilà bienvenue dans le canton de cernet
qui recouvre aujourd'hui toute la vallée
de laat la vallée depuis son début
wildildenstein avec toutes les les
questions liées à l'aménagement de la
montagne lié à la valorisation de la
montagne sur l'aspect agriculture
tourisme jusqu'à son débouché à Cerny
qui qui s'ouvre rapidement sur sur le
bassin mulousien c'est un canton qui est
à la croisée de beaucoup de de chemins
historique
historiquement beaucoup de vestiges
beaucoup de patrimoine est présente dans
le
canton je pense que la la meilleure
incarnation c'est sûrement la la
collégiale de tane qui est un des trois
chef-dœuvres de l'architecture gothique
et puis ensuite toute l'histoire
industrielle de l'Alsace qu'on retrouve
dans notre canton avec l'histoire
textile qui a fortement marqué notre
territoire notamment dans la dans la
vallée et puis l'histoire chimique aussi
l'histoire automobile également puisque
Cerny le canton de cernet se trouve à la
croisée de deux routes celle du nord au
sud avec toute la question de l'aut
l'automobile entre entre bfort et et
mulouse celle d'est en ouest avec la
question du textile et puis la route
verbale avec toutes les activités liées
à la chimie et puis on se retrouve aussi
dans un espace assez mine de rien rural
avec des une activité agricole encore
très présente avec de l'élevage mais
aussi beaucoup d'agriculture de culture
et et notamment de viticulture puisque
le canton marque la porte sud de la
route des vins d'Alsace avec tan et son
célèbre Grand Cru k Rangen le canton de
cernet s'inscrit aussi dans son futur
dans le développement et nous sommes ici
sur la zone d'activité d'intérêt
départemental d'aspacleut c'est ici que
s'installe actuellement et que
continueront à s'installer dans les
prochaines années de nouvelles activités
économiques de nouvelles entreprises et
la création de nouveaux emplois c'est
cette stratégie portée par le
département mais par les collectivité
locale également qui nous permet dans le
territoire de sortir de la spirale dans
laquelle la crise textile nous avait
emmené nous sommes aussi
ici au bord d'un projet d'infrastructure
pour le département qu le barreau
routier qui reliera la RN66 à l'bac et
Roderen il permettra de déservir cette
zone mais il permettra aussi et surtout
de fluidifier le trafic sur la RN66 en
aval de Tan pour une vallée qui souffre
particulièrement de la surcharge de cet
axe qui est le seul axe qu'elle connaît
voilà c'est cette image d'un
canton ancré dans ses valeurs ancré dans
son moine mais aussi tourner vers
l'avenir que je souhaitais partager avec
vous
aujourd'hui